what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start guys can we please get to
2 000 likes this video make sure you
like the video that is the most
important metric that YouTube uses to
push out these videos also guys if you
want to be the ultimate alpha male
the ultimate
IDGAF guy get yourself a women shouldn't
vote t-shirt today you will have women
left and right coming up to you just
saying how amazing you are how much they
just enjoy your shirt right so get get
your women shouldn't vote sure um the
link is in the description also we're
thinking about adding one to two more
designs up to the site so if you guys
have a certain phrase that you really
like that we've talked about
um put it in the comments like what
would you like to have on a t-shirt okay
so
um today we are we got a lot going on
we got a lot going on guys you already
know Pearl is always tweeting I'm always
on Twitter I'm like the the queen of the
tweets it's like you get I'm like Oprah
on Twitter you get a tweet you get a
tweet you get a tweet okay so a lot of
the stories we're gonna cover today do
involve Twitter but this one I actually
did see on Tick Tock so as you guys may
or may not know Steve Harvey has been in
some hot water so there have been rumors
that Steve Harvey's wife Marjorie
cheated with his chef and his bodyguard
now
to be fair Steve does deny these rumors
so we don't know a hundred percent if
this is true however looking at their
relationship Dynamic throughout the
years uh the shoe fits I mean Steve
married a woman who needs the spotlight
it's very obvious she seems to lead the
relationship and a single mother
um in my opinion A lot of them tend to
be pretty predatory and they just kind
of Run game around these rich men that
don't understand female nature so I saw
a clip of Steve after he got married
um speaking about Marjorie and his
prenup so let's pull the clip when I
married Marjorie I had something but we
didn't do a prenup because I knew this
is the chick I'm going to the tape
they do not yeah um this is kind of what
happens when you put chicks on a
pedestal you know women are women and in
my opinion
um I understand the religious point of
view where it's like okay
um you know you don't want to plan for
something to fail
but [__] we are supposed to be
virgins it's like all these Christian
ladies will come in and be like my
religion says my religion says I can't
do a prenup well how convenient our
religion also says you're supposed to be
a virgin on your wedding day and the
point is just it's like blatant
hypocrisy like women want traditionalism
but only when it benefits us
um so okay we're not gonna bring
virginity but that's okay we have a past
Sorry God here I go down the aisle um
now I'm even gonna burn a kid I'm even
gonna bring a child but a prenup that's
that's where I draw the line and Steve
Harvey honestly is a naive guy I would
say and the only way he's really gotten
women is by playing their games the
problem is when men have a nature and
it's usually from single mother homes or
men with like a very domineering mother
and you can usually tell it's a
domineering mother if she's pretty
career oriented if um uh she talks over
her husband
um they they'll a lot of times the
domineering mothers will say well it's
about balance which really means it's
about my way or the highway I mean like
when have women ever been balanced
it's like they just yeah
yeah Diane yeah a lot of balance here
balance oh okay anyway so
um in my opinion if a woman is gonna
come to you as a traditional woman that
means raised to be a wife you know
learned her grandmother's recipes that
were passed down to her
no one has I'll just save you the time
no one has if she comes to you under the
age of say 25
um if she comes to you as a virgin then
then we can talk about religion and
traditionalism but if she doesn't come
to you like that it's like okay we
picked modern so expect modern I I don't
see a problem with a prenup
um especially with all that men have to
lose today and I and what I don't like
about Steve is he basically says if men
don't do exactly what you ask then
they don't know about you well what the
hell were Men supposed to know how are
they supposed to know when they'll know
at the aisle and then as that woman is
taking their kids half their assets and
putting them on child support for 18
years they're like wait I thought I knew
Bob John and Timmy all knew they knew
she was the one well look at where they
are now guys The Jig Is up women The Jig
Is up men are wising up they're done
with this once a cheater always a
cheater Steve he sounds like you don't
no what happens is you can make mistakes
and grow from it and learn from it but
then every time a man cheats doesn't
mean you have to give him another chance
either all men can change but there is
only one woman we will change for the
gym and she said uh what she said Jimmy
you know what Steve he's he's so much
like my dad
[Music]
the hair she would have just took her
ass into the kitchen and cooked for her
[__] man she would have known
this [__] hey don't let this segment
mess our marriage
recently contacted by individuals from
his initial team Marjorie had dismissed
all of them and they referred to her as
the green eyed monster they've observed
her frequently with Steve we only adapt
for one woman if he isn't making
adjustments there's little we can expect
there's a whirlwind of accusations
online aimed at Steve and Marjorie
suggesting infidelity within their
marriage the online community is a buzz
speculating if this could be the end for
the couple Steve Harvey and Marjorie
Harvey are currently embroiled in a
scandal after podcaster Tasha K alleged
on Instagram that Steve had an affair
with his attractive private Chef this
comes as a shock as the couple had
managed to keep their relationships
Scandal free for years on an episode of
unwind with Tasha K she discussed the
rumor surrounding Steve and his private
Chef suggesting he had been unfaithful
to Marjorie Tasha's allegations have
quickly caught attention though we
haven't been able to independently
verify their accuracy Tasha K runs a
popular podcast but it has occasionally
been accused of spreading untruths about
celebrities notably she faced legal
action from hip-hop artist cardi B and
during the proceedings Tasha confessed
to fabricating stories about cardi
however despite these claims by Tasha
sources close to Steve and the chef
insist that their relationship is purely
professional still Tasha's podcast has
ignited a social media storm with
discussions about Steve and the chef a
seasoned professional becoming
widespread notably it was mentioned that
the woman has been associated with Steve
Harvey since 2005 yet remains unmarried
to him
yeah so Tasha K started this look I know
I know Tasha's getting sued by cardi
okay I know but she's kind of funny you
know what I you know I mean she's a
celebrity blogger it's like they're
bound to get one or two things wrong
um I I do believe that Marjorie has
cheated with somebody it's just I've
just seen too many of these relationship
Dynamics from gold digging women and
this just tends to be how it goes we
don't know for sure so this is all
speculatory
um and I actually feel bad for Steve
because really
um he was probably raised by a mother
that told him this
and a lot of men that want to do the
right thing you know no prenup really
more traditional uh are punished but
then I don't feel bad because he's lied
to us women for 20 years 20 years even
like listen to this any man can change
but he's only gonna change for one woman
so what is that what does that imply
that you the woman can be so special and
amazing that you yourself are gonna make
a man change his ways no no no no men
change sometimes for themselves because
they faced consequences or they're at
the time in their life where they're
gonna settle down but any man that's
gonna change for you
honestly is a man that's gonna drive you
nuts again I I believe in a natural
order of the world I really think it
goes God
maybe government I haven't decided God
possibly government men women children
and I think when you disrupt the order
and the men start listening to the women
and following the women one we hate it
we hate it and the worst part is all of
these dating advice guys tell us to do
this to put all these rules on the guys
to the to control the guys when really
The Men We want can't be controlled we
can't make them do anything
and the men that allow us to control
them we're gonna hate for a lifetime it
just doesn't work so on one hand I I
don't know I I go back and forth with
Steve because sometimes I do think he
believes the stuff he says I mean [__]
he married a single mother I mean no
prenup I mean that's pretty far to go if
you don't believe it and I do believe
there's a whole generation of men that
believe this stuff but the problem is
it's not reality and now there's a whole
generation that's been misled by Steve
Harvey's advice so now we have a clip
that's gonna go over what the people are
saying how are how are people reacting
to this if this rumor is true about
Steve Harvey and Marjorie Steve Harvey
you blind
real [__] man you blind you mean to tell
me you didn't learn anything from your
stepdaughter
where do you think your stepdaughter
learned her behavior from her mom
look your mother is your first teacher
you see the way your stepdaughter
bounces from this man to that man to
that man to this man what do you think
she got her counseling from her mom your
wife yo you yo you I'm done I'm done you
know this guy is absolutely right women
do learn behavior from their mothers and
guys this is why you know
guys will say don't marry women with
tattoo sleeves don't marry women that
have slept around don't marry women that
have children outside of wedlock don't
marry single mothers like there's a
reason that we say these things and it's
not to be mean and it's not to oh be a
doom and gloom person whatever but the
truth of the matter is if you're a woman
you weren't raised to be a wife you
gotta work really hard to learn
or your kids are going to turn out worse
works and the problem is we have an
entire generation of people that were
raised by working women
uh women that put their careers and
their needs first not their husbands and
money doesn't change it success doesn't
change it uh the truth of the matter is
we can see with Steve Harvey uh with
Lori Harvey that she's got success Fame
all of that stuff
and yet what happened see
she turned down Michael B Jordan it's
like and her mom co-signed and her dad
said oh you're a queen you can do better
oh my gosh and then her dad or her
stepdad says well what is what do the
men bring to the table
it's like
I don't know this is
everything's backwards guys everything's
backwards and all I'm trying to do is
point out how we can bring It Forward
okay so the next story really plays into
evolutionary psychology so women love
murderers
um you know it's funny because ten
percent of our ancestors killed each
other I can't remember the exact time
period but literally ten percent
um and it really helped you as a chick
to pick a a murderer yeah because if
your guy was murdering the other guys at
least you're not gonna get murdered
right you know there's evolutionary
reasons why we feel the way we feel
and we can't necessarily help it so when
you have armed guards that are women
policing inmates I have a couple
questions one what on Earth
is a woman gonna do
in a prison with a bunch of men
I I just think that's like a waste of
taxpayer dollars you're gonna put a
chick
to
keep down uh inmate uprising like she's
gonna do [__] but I I don't really get
surprised when I see women that are
throwing themselves at the inmates and
this video I thought was so funny
because this lady uh basically was
caught sleeping with an inmate and they
they literally they they show her a
recording of her like talking dirty with
the inmate she still denies it she
denies it to the just pull the clip you
talk to him on any Jail phone calls or
anything like that
oh no not at all let me go out of camera
view or anything like that anything
that's going to look suspicious that way
I just won the blackjack game
yay
I got a lot of stuff to clean and get
rid of before you come home
yeah I bet you do what what
what do you mean I don't know you
probably got this weird sex sling
hanging from the ceiling can't assign
things it's a swing set oh if I had that
sex swing you better believe I'd leave
that [__] up for you would you really
hell yeah yeah let me put you in it
yeah with a gag bar and everything
yeah
how that sounds from my my point of view
like a more recent thing than three
years ago
no the audacity she has to say no after
hearing that phone call is truly
remarkable but to her credit she's not
going down easily the detectives try
asking her if she thinks Jason would
cover for her and she still doesn't
break sticking to her story that
everything that happened happened
outside of prison
just as the detectives say things really
aren't adding up yet she's still
sticking to her story or at least she
was before a switch flipped and she said
this what is it
um
how long ago was that uh
the Secret's out and Charlene has
confessed
wow okay did you see yeah
all right one women love criminals we
love them like there's a reason guys
guys and all the women will be like oh
that's only the bad women the bad women
only guys you can't you think you you're
shocked the women are so special they
think they can beat evolution
you think you can that's that's why we
had dads that's why the dads were so
important because it was like stay away
stay away from my daughter criminal bad
boy drug deal they would keep them away
now now we're more likely to we are more
likely to make children with violent
criminals
now now the funny part about this whole
story you see how she tried she tried so
hard to lie her way out
she tried so hard at first she's like
okay yeah we slept together but it was a
couple it was years ago and they're like
uh okay where what happened oh I don't
she tried she tried so hard
and now and now the tables have turned
yeah and now you know she basically
tried to lie that way then she tried to
say they're making it up and then she's
like all right all right it happened it
yeah
um but now you know she she might be a
criminal herself because criminals
cannot consent and it's funny we all
know this lady's gonna get off I mean
and more than one way you know but but
like it's funny because with the Harvey
Weinstein thing right everyone said oh
the women were taken advantage of when
they slept with him for roles but in
this situation I just don't think the
men are really going to be seen as
victims
I mean they're they're victims I mean
she was in a position of power where are
the feminists put put this lady on the
front page
of all of the magazines
they don't care they don't and that's
the thing when when the roles are
reversed and and this is why
I say we're either equal or we're not
equal so if we're equal okay then be
treated like a man and have the same
consequences as a man but if we're not
equal
um then give up some of the freedom you
know and that that's the thing sexism
really does it benefits women because it
acknowledges that men and women aren't
the same and usually gives us special
privileges
um and takes away some of the
responsibility but the problem is women
want all the responsibility we want to
be in these hard jobs we want to do all
this stuff and
we want all of the freedom too and the
privilege uh but we can't you can't have
it both ways it's either one or the
other so I noticed a political
commentator Matt Walsh and Matt Walsh
works for the daily wire
um and he really got famous for a
documentary that he did on trans
um people basically he did like
interviews and asked like what is a
woman and he recently gave this take on
a tick tock that went viral and is good
and is giving a lot of heat it's 10 45
a.m on a Saturday I'm 29 and single and
I don't have kids yet here's what your
Saturday morning looks like when you're
single at 29 and you don't have a kid
running around the house I didn't rise
from my bed until 10 15. every time I
thought I should probably get up and do
something I thought why nobody's making
me I'm not missing out on anything I
went to Beyonce last night and I didn't
get home until 1am and I danced and
drank my little heart out and I didn't
pay a babysitter to watch my kids as I
did that and I woke up at Tad hungover
this morning which is probably why I was
in bed for so long and I was just
scrolling on my phone and I saw a
picture of Shaq Shuka and I thought you
know it sounds really good maybe I'm
gonna learn how to make shakshuka today
because I have no plans and I don't have
kids and I don't have a husband and I
don't have errands to run I can go to
the grocery store and learn how to make
shakshuka so that's on my agenda today
also on my agenda probably a re-watch of
some Real Housewives of New York I'm
also doing a re-watch of normal people
on Hulu which is really spicy and I
highly recommend weirdly I'm into this
documentary on Netflix about Blue Zone
countries so I've got a pretty stock day
anyway I say all this to say whenever
I'm hard on myself about why I'm not
married and I don't have kids and I
should be further along at 29 almost 30.
I wouldn't want to do anything else this
Saturday I know that you can do all
these things when you have kids and
you're married and I understand but the
effortlessness and ease of my life just
kind of focusing on myself and the
shakshuk I want to make or the Beyonce
concert I want to go to really pays off
when I'm hard on myself for not being
where Society tells me I should be in
life so Matt tweets this Tick Tock and
he said
he said her life doesn't revolve around
her family and kids so instead it
revolves around TV shows and pop stars
worst of all she's too stupid to realize
how depressing this is now what I want
to say is Matt lives in reality
this is true and guys there is a whole
generation of women like this they're
predicting 45 percent of us are going to
be single and childless now the other
half of women with kids what percent of
them are going to be single mothers uh
they say half of kids born today are
single mothers
um so now you maybe have 20 25 percent
of women
that are going to be married with kids
for a lifetime yeah and what percent of
the married ones get divorced and the
truth is we're in a post-marriage
society we just don't know it yet and a
lot of trap I think Matt's kind of
catching up I think I've seen him kind
of get a little red pilled I think he's
catching on
um but a lot of the a lot of the Trad
cons
um don't realize that we really are in a
post-marriage society I look around at
places that are under 40. like I went to
this roller rink the other day and it
just kind of amazed me because I
realized like when I was a kid it would
have been all families but now it's all
it's all single people
and and Matt's right and a lot of a lot
of women have no idea what's coming
um they have no idea what's coming now
now let's start let's let's analyze his
statements one by one and ask are they
true because what I need from us us
women especially and you simp men I'm so
tired I just cannot deal with the
pandering anymore I am tired I have done
a year and a half of shows with all of
these men that just simp for a lifetime
and a time and I'm done I'm done I don't
wanna I us women have to come together
and say we do not want to be pandered to
anymore I am so tired of simps catering
the message to get sex from us to get us
to buy things or to build their brand
they just all they want is to make money
off of women so they will Pander to us
for a lifetime and tell us we'll be
young forever will be hot forever will
be amazing forever we are so special and
perfect and the truth is we're not most
women don't bring much to the table most
women weren't raised to be wives and you
can't fix a problem unless we admit it
exists and the the problem is they don't
let us live in reality and so I think
commentators like Matt for being honest
um so he says
her life doesn't revolve around her
family and kids so instead it revolves
around TV shows and pop stars is the is
that true or is it false guys
and that that's the thing like that's
what we have to ask that's true that's
what she said worst of all she's too
stupid to realize how depressing this is
um is this true or is it false because
she said I think she said I like 50
times in that tick tock and she said I
wouldn't want to do anything else focus
on myself you know and that's delusion
right there there's a difference by
saying I am sad to be in this situation
that's honest what she's doing is cope
pretending to be happy when clearly
she's not and I would much rather men be
honest
rather than let us live in delusion for
a lifetime so this set off conservatives
and liberals alike hi my name is Julie
and I'm 29 and single yesterday someone
named Matt Walsh decided to repost a
tick tock video that I posted to his 2.4
million followers on X formerly known as
Twitter and the way that his followers
bullied me in the comments reached out
to me on social media threatened me was
honestly abhorrent some of his followers
said that I was gonna die alone I should
actually die and never leave my house I
should be sexually assaulted I'm
pathetic I'm a [__] and that I was dead
behind my eyes honestly that one kind of
made me laugh because I use kosa's
concealer and I thought that it was
working no but really if you haven't
watched the video I suggest you watch it
it's all about how I a 29 year old
single female decided to spend my
Saturday watching reality TV learning
how to cook shakshuka and sleeping in
until 10 a.m these people were really
really really riled up about my choices
on a Saturday but here's the thing about
social media while it can be a really
crazy place which I experienced
yesterday it's a place where there's
content for everyone here's who I'm
creating content for I'm creating
content for people who are taking their
time creating the lives that they want
for themselves because it's the life
that that they want not something that
Society has deemed correct people who
are feeling anxious in life because they
haven't met their person yet or started
a family aren't rushing or settling to
meet someone because some internet troll
is telling them that they're going to
die alone and you know what there's a 40
to 50 percent divorce rate in the U.S
and I believe that figuring out who you
are first and foremost and meeting your
partner at that point is going to
decrease that divorce rate and if you're
lucky enough to have the family and
friends and support that I do none of us
are going to die alone and I believe
that we're all going to meet our people
and we're going to do it living life by
our own terms Life's too short to be
living life figuring out what Matt Walsh
wants us to do or what some internet
troll behind their keyboard is saying if
anyone is wondering the shakshuk I made
was delicious and I'd love to share the
recipe if anyone's interested
okay so I wrote down a couple things she
said
um
because she
I'm making content and you know I'm
butchering this I'm not sucking you know
I she said I'm making content for people
taking their time creating the life they
want
women I mean that's that's single women
okay
um then she says that are anxious right
and and when do we get anxious late 20s
early 30s okay not rushing or settling
and this is the problem she doesn't know
what's going on in the dating Market
and so it's so funny because women hear
this but they don't know what's going on
the truth of the matter is we have women
that are fours five sixes seven sleeping
with eight nines and tens and now when
they get to their husband they feel like
they're settling when really all of
their exes were just out of their league
that's what's going on every dating app
will tell you that every matchmaking
service will tell you that and the truth
of the matter is
um most women will have to settle most
people are average and and I actually
don't even like that term settle because
most people get what they deserve and
the truth of the matter is the best
women get get wifed up before 25.
that's and and that's okay ladies like
we can cope with this can we cope let's
cope
men will look at other men and say all
right that's the richest most handsome
men that's the best man that most women
would go for
um but us women can't come together and
say okay that chick over there the best
the hottest the most desired women are
gone before 25.
uh without whining and crying and
attacking the messenger you know what I
mean and
um the other lie is that we all have one
person it's this Disney fairy tale that
the media sells to us to keep us single
for a lifetime because we're better
consumers
um they can manipulate the market a lot
better when we're just swiping our
credit cards 24 7. the problem we have
with women is we take everything
personally right it's me me me me and
the truth of the matter is 45 of women
are going to be single and childless
it's not just her
um there is an entire and that's
probably who watches her podcast it's
single women
um that are in their late 20s early 30s
that are probably going to die alone and
that's and this doesn't sound nice this
isn't the ending that we can sell on TV
and just that sounds amazing but this is
this is the truth that will help you
because even if you're single for a
lifetime do you really do most women
have 2.5 million to retire
genuinely do most women have the money
to live a life alone the Society isn't
meant for single women the average woman
makes like thirty five thousand dollars
a year
how is that going to last her a lifetime
what is she going to do in retirement
um and if women do get married then you
can be a little more aware that women
only go for the top 10 20 percent of men
so if you have a list of Standards it
might be better to lower it and fathers
Brothers uncles used to tell us this
information women have always been women
since the beginning of time the
peasant's wife has always left for the
king if given the chance that has always
happened but there have been
institutions to protect women from
ourselves female promiscuity and the
truth of the matter is really if you
aren't a virgin on your wedding day you
would have historically been considered
a concubine look I don't I don't say
this in like a happy way but women have
been lied to and commentators like Matt
are at least honest and if you're gonna
put [__] on the internet expect people
to comment expect them and and now all
of this simps came in all up so let's
let's let's show the simp commentators
this guy randomly shaming a single women
for having a lazy Saturday is a Surefire
way to announce you're a good guy
following Jesus
um again you can only I hate the word
shaming because nobody can make you feel
shame that that comes from within
um and the truth of the matter is if
this was a guy nobody would care and do
you know what's so funny if this was a
guy and he said yeah I spent my Saturday
playing video games
um I'm so glad I don't have children
um all of the travel best believe all
the Trad cons would come in and say well
why don't you have a wife and a family
oh my gosh they all would they all oh
that's the funny that is the funny thing
okay a dumb [__] Capital wow under
sexed men hate to see single beautiful
women over the age of 25 because at that
age she's rejected many men men like him
who she doesn't want to settle for well
again see there's that word I don't like
that word settle
it's like is it settling or is it
getting what what we earned you know
what I mean and this isn't a bad thing
right okay like if we have a Honda Civic
and a BMW is it bad for a Honda Civic to
get Honda Civic prices but this is the
thing women will protect other women's
feelings from the truth and we should be
mad at the women that don't let us live
in reality it's not kind it doesn't help
us and I'm so sick of seeing it
um they obsess over the wall and
fetishize these women dying alone
because it's a Revenge it's a the
Revenge kill the cheerleader fantasy
that certain men will never get over no
matter how old they get the funny thing
is in history most men haven't
reproduced this isn't a new phenomenon
what is a new phenomenon is women not
reproducing and I'm sorry but what Matt
is saying is more honest and more true
than anything any of these Save A Hoe
simp women and men are gonna do at least
with Matt's message
you can live in Ria and that's really
the biggest thing I push here is just
living in reality it's not settling if
the guys you want don't watch you uh
then it's just getting what you deserve
and it's okay to not deserve the world
like it's it doesn't have to be the
end-all be-all thing the best women are
under the age of 25 or under 30 or
whatever you want to do right it's like
it you can acknowledge like it's okay to
just be a normal person most people are
normal
um and most normal women aren't gonna
have Happy Endings and it's sad because
we have so many people pandering to us
as a as a woman I'd like to say Matt
Walsh thank you for being honest thank
you because I am really just tired of
the pandering and I am tired of women
being told we're Queens no matter what
that none of our life choices have any
consequences and if anyone makes an
observation about our lives it's like
it's it's now shaming it's shaming
um and I'm also really tired of hearing
the world settle
um yeah
then everybody settles because nobody
gets a perfect husband or a perfect wife
then
anyways thank you Matt I appreciate it
okay
now I don't know what it is about us
women but we just have an inclination to
never be happy and to nitpick into wine
you know a man men are just generally
more content with life like they'll have
a good job good benefits and they'll say
okay I'm a happy camper but women just
we have a tendency to whine uh it
doesn't mean we're bad people but I mean
I think we can acknowledge there's some
patterns and one pattern I notice is
women will want to be in a man's world
they'll say please let me into a man's
world oh please God please God let me in
I want to be in and then they get in and
they tell men how to talk they start
policing the language you can't say that
this is bullying
um and then wine even when they're given
immense opportunities so let's let's go
the past [__] month that I've worked
at Barstool It's Made Me
hate working at Barstool just gonna say
that
um men suck and I felt I've been feeling
attacked in every sense of for just
being a woman and if a guy was doing any
of the same [__] that I was doing it
wouldn't be
blink. twice also all of the people that
are mad at me on the internet for my
relationship now out of control it's
like
why is it the woman's fault why and I
don't want them to be mad at Zach but
it's like he did the same exact thing
yeah but he's God yeah I'm the bad
person I just because I'm a woman this
whole new switch up narrative on on you
and how people feel about you is [__]
insane because of who dates crazy it's
like who gives a [__] bro I know well
that's what just now I'm just like
I can't even I can't even
explain how like infuriating it is to
like see all of
all of this like people that have never
seen me before or watched any of my
content or like listen to plan Brie or
like know us or anything about us just
like have this crazy idea of me and who
I am but that's the internet so it's
like I can't get mad about it it goes
back to like you can't accept positive
feedback you can't accept negative
feedback you just have to exist and
accept the feedback of the people in
your life which has been working and I'm
so [__] happy man you've really
carried yourself well through all this I
just I don't know how the [__] you're
doing it okay so a little back story on
this Brie had a boyfriend right and she
had a boyfriend for I don't know like a
year maybe
um
then she dumps said boyfriend and gets
with a a superstar you know um the Zach
something I don't know he's some country
I should know this I like country music
but Zach Brown Zach Brian Zach something
anyways he's like number one right now
when all the country hits he's he's
phenomenal
she dumped her boyfriend and then got
with this guy right after now he also
had a girlfriend and dumped her and then
got with her right after
um and there was a lot of speculation
that there was cheating but they both
say there wasn't so I'm not Pearl out of
the kindness of my heart I give the
benefit of the doubt but I mean come on
this is us women again we'll always dump
the peasant for the king
I mean I never heard of her ex-boyfriend
but I I certainly know who she's dating
now
and yeah um that just doesn't look bad
and so the first thing she whines about
is that she's attacked for being she
says I've been feeling attacked now
again this shows that us women it's
based on how we feel first rather than
reality just because you feel attacked
doesn't mean you are
um and you know her show they like cover
gossip and she does it with Dave
portnoyed and then this other guy and
again you know I mean it it it looks bad
now she wants to know now Bree I'm gonna
give you a nice answer I'm gonna help
you men and women aren't the same so we
do have different standards when it
comes to relationships and women are
supposed to be like the emotionally
loyal one
you know that's like our thing
um and yeah women look worse when they
hop from guy to guy to guy now I'm not
I'm not even like hate like they
actually seem like a cute couple uh but
what I don't like is now you're gonna
say well men suck because of my choice
which didn't doesn't look very good
um I mean again women are supposed to be
loyal for a lifetime that's the original
monogamy is getting married as a virgin
and you stay with one guy forever
and you know in history the Kings would
have concubines and multiple women so
that's not really like we can try to
rewrite biology but it's still biology
and whining and crying and saying how
you hate working for bar school stool
publicly like I this is so disrespectful
a platform that's giving you everything
you're gonna say men suck and
I've been feeling attacked you know I
just it's like where a man would come
into this and think well I'm paid a lot
I'm famous I have an awesome show
life is good and you know that's why I
also say women aren't really meant to
deal with men's problems because a lot
of us can't handle it and you see this
you see it firsthand
um her her boyfriend I you know what I'm
sure I've seen Zach get attacked on Tick
Tock so I'm not even gonna I don't even
believe this all the women were whining
about his ex-girlfriend
um yeah so he's got an attack too the
difference is men just don't really
whine they're really not whiners men are
a lot more content but and I'd like to
say I do
I am I feel a little bad doing this
because I'm kind of a I like her stuff
but it's more to point out the trend
where women we just aren't happy we tend
to leave for a better guy
um and the way we measure that is
typically money status looks Etc
um
and we process things with feelings
first so she's been feeling attacked and
we want to be in a man's world but we
don't want to take what comes with it
which is special privilege and when we
want we want all the privilege of being
a woman right women have to work women
do not have to work as hard at all in
media to get as big of a following as a
woman I can say this I've managed man
and I've managed women oh my God it is
so much easier with women
please stop please stop like I
so we get we get women privileges but
then we whine about the Privileges we
don't get and yeah men get to [__] a lot
of chicks and No One's Gonna bat an eye
but if we date a lot of dudes it looks
bad I I don't make the rules I just tell
you what they are so don't be mad at me
for telling you okay so speaking of
women never being happy you know
now you'll say pearl you're just making
this up women are such grateful happy
campers and they don't ask for a lot
well there's a trend of a tick tock
account that I found that is actually
making a list of X so what is a Nick an
ick basically is a when a woman gets a a
feeling in her stomach ick and so he's
writing down all the things that women
say
not to do now is this list reasonable
well let's let's let's show um the
original Tick Tock in the Stitch video
so this guy wrote down
168x wait
I don't get cancer
hey
so I'm gonna read you guys uh I'm gonna
read you some of these icks these super
reasonable X now imagine if the tables
were turned and Men wrote down small
boobs ick
um bags under her eyes ick flat butt ick
um like all of this stuff or talks too
much ick all of the women would say ah
ah you can't you misogynist
I'm just tired I'm so tired so I'm going
to read you some of these don't smile as
a Nick don't be truthful as a neck don't
tie your shoes don't walk downhill don't
be born on a certain month or listen to
country music don't have a birthday
don't get cold don't fall over don't
bath don't have a hobby don't carry a
bag don't watch football don't breathe
Friendly Fire don't miscount don't have
emotion when hurting yourself don't use
a trampoline properly don't skip a step
don't taste any yogurt don't jump at a
concert don't be a man don't get hit by
a car don't blow up a bed
um don't blow up a blow up bed don't put
on car blinkers don't look at animals in
the zoo don't use emojis don't laugh
don't go on a diving board don't breathe
when talking don't have a shower don't
go bowling don't have pineapple on Pizza
don't be named something starting with a
J don't run in water don't eat chicken
nuggets don't have a little Willy don't
have an Android don't ask for consent
don't have a velcro wallet don't play
Muse don't move your toes
now I already hear the women well we're
just kidding we're just kidding this is
just all funny funny just kid we're not
serious really there's no truth to 168
videos
foreign it's like okay we say things the
men take notes and then we whine we
whine when we could just live in reality
and say yeah we're just like never happy
it's all right doesn't mean you're a bad
person it's just you know women just
have a tendency to get greedy and want
more I don't know what it is we just
we're like that
that's reality you know
it is what it is like okay you know
what's so funny guys I had a manager
once that told me I need to stop going
after Trad cons to appeal to a broader
audience that's what I was told and I
just can't do it I just I live in TR
like not my truth I'm searching for the
truth and when I see something that's
out of order I just can't not commentate
on it like I could go after feminists
all day but you know it makes me really
sad the state of churches okay it makes
it genuinely makes me sad as a Catholic
right that we are now pandering to women
in church and now the reputation of
women in the church is worse than the
reputation outside of the church and
whenever we talk about these problems
I'm accused for I'm accused of going
after religion when I think religion is
a great thing I think it's an amazing
thing but we have started pandering in a
house of God literally the house of God
is meant to be
uh for the truth the truth but churches
only demonize male sin and never female
sin uh for example and I use this almost
as a litmus test okay to see how woke a
church is uh would you say that men
should only marry virgins that should be
an easy yes
I mean exceptions don't make the rule
guys but they'll say well I mean
good luck most men can't handle a virgin
really
every guy used to get one they could
handle them just like
um but and so and it's like every
woman's born that so if we raised better
kids
um
yeah that could happen you know I mean
it's not I'm not saying that's the trend
where the culture is going
um and we just have this like tendency
to Pander and tell women what they want
to hear in church
um and now we start to get these
delusional Christian women so far it's
so bad guys that I went to um a small
town in northern Wisconsin
and men in the town told me that the
church made their wives worse these are
guys that got virgin wives Christian
women like cream of the crop and still
they say they are Brainwashed the women
go and get brainwashed by Church the
house of God and what the Christians
will do is they'll say this is just an
anomaly uh this isn't a general Trend
across the board oh it's across the
board it's in all I'm Catholic it's in
the Catholic Church you know and I spoke
to a priest last time I was home
um I went to a church and it was a
different Church than I went to growing
up I just kind of was trying a different
one and the priest um I talked to him
after because I wanted to get a priest
on the channel and he literally told me
that there are certain things he can't
say because the diocese will get mad or
whatever and again that's what you get
when you get feminine men in leadership
and and women
um and and the priests at least banned
the women from Big priests thank god oh
we would become we would have gay flags
everywhere in Catholic churches if that
didn't happen but still there are
certain things they can't talk about you
know I've never heard a pastor say you
know God can forgive you women for your
sins but men don't have to that's honest
and the truth of the matter is 45 of
women are going to be single and
childless
45 percent
and they're told we're told we're all
going to have a happy ending when half
of us are not a quarter of women over 40
now are single and childless uh the
truth is a lot of people are not going
to have Happy Endings a lot of people
are not going to be bailed out of our
bad decisions and the truth is we
deserve whatever we get for the
decisions that we made and some women
are going to have to start planning um
accordingly and saving money to die
alone some women need to get married
it's really gonna
I mean it it depends on the chick right
but the truth is the church sells these
women dreams
dreams and and here here's the byproduct
okay
genuine question where are all the
single Christian men because they're not
in church where are they they're not in
Home Depot they're not in the grocery
store they're not in tart like where are
these men this is not a drill I just
turned 30. if you know any christian
single men that also happen to look like
Tom Cruise
throughout this video I'm just kidding
they don't have to look like Tom Cruise
I also like Jake Gyllenhaal anyways
happy Labor Day
God Bless America
okay do you see how crazy this I mean
this chick's cute
but it's still a 30 year old chick is
asking for a guy that looks like Tom
Cruise or Jake Gyllenhaal can we put
like a side by side does that look like
can we can we like put in edit where we
put in like the girls that they these
men have dated versus this chick like
this is still like do you see how this
sounds and and they'll say haha I'm just
kidding guys kidding has an element of
Truth all right and it's not just her
it's women across the board we're just
getting more and more delusional okay
it's getting crazy and you know
um why are the men leaving the church
that's the question and this is what
they'll do the men will leave churches
and the church men will say okay well
the men just aren't good enough that's
the reason they're leaving no no no no
no no men are leaving because the
churches have turned into a concert with
snacks they've taken all the order out
of the church they only talk about male
sin and never talk about female sin that
talk about men's porn addiction but
never talk about women's addiction to
attention and social media they'll talk
about men sleeping around but they'll
never talk about women not being virgins
on their wedding day all they do is simp
and they Pander to women and it doesn't
help us and then you get this as the
outcome and if you look at a lot of
these churches their top donors are
single women and so all of the media all
of the messaging in society and even in
churches is pandered to women instead of
being honest with us the best women are
under the age of 25 that's honest that's
true
the best stuff gets bought it's okay
um it doesn't mean you're a bad person
it doesn't mean
that it's over but I think if we can't
acknowledge there's room for improvement
in the women in and out of the church
then we're just going to start living in
delusion and we're not going to have
better outcomes and that's why guys in
the red pill are are needed guys like
Myron are needed guys like Kevin Samuels
are needed because they're honest where
everyone else is just trying to make
money off of us
they're trying to make money off of us
or they're trying to get laid or they're
trying to look good and virtuous I
cannot stand the virtue signaling and
that's why I cannot stand all of these
guys that are coming for Matt Walsh
um saying that he's shaming a woman uh
he's being honest and we need to applaud
honesty as women and we need to get sick
of this [__] because I'm tired of being
pandered to and all women should get
together and just be sick and tired of
being pandered to because it doesn't
help us and it leads to a crazy Society
this is this is this is what pandering
to us for 50 years has led to women
being more depressed than ever before
women being sadder than ever before
women being lonelier than ever before
this is what it's led to
um so I would much rather have someone
tell me the harsh truth than let me live
in delusion so uh let me know what you
guys think in the comments maybe Pearl's
just a crazy lady just
so mean
or maybe I'm being honest so let me know
what you guys think in the comments um
like the video on your way out and get
yourself a women shouldn't vote t-shirt
today all of these problems started when
women got the right to vote so join the
movement get your t-shirt in the
description like the video and I'll talk
to you next time